so well I know that the previous battles
inside of the Tokyo Colony were pure
fire however we are now flying over to
another colony where the battles have
escalated far far quicker quickly
surpassing the brutality of Tokyo turned
in the bustling city of Sendai into a
domain of pure viciousness just before
we do get into the video though if you
are new around here and want to watch
more content just like this where I go
over a bunch of arcs and fights from
throughout a bunch of different series
then make sure you hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video as it really helps out with
pushing my content to a bunch of new
amazing people so yes just like I
previously mentioned we have now left
the Tokyo Colony number one wiiuchi and
migami are to fly over to Keke's other
main character they no longer depressed
Yuta akotsu who's currently in the
Sendai Colony there are currently four
powerhouses at the center of the
conflict and just like the Tokyo Colony
Cinder here has also reached a deadlock
due to only the PowerHouse has been left
over drove like dewala is a veteran of
the Civil War of War a war in which it
was like literally him versus everyone
else so the dude must have been pure
Insanity it's explain that he currently
sits at 91 points and has the ability to
use two kinds of independent shikigami
that can compose a domain with their
like orbiting thingies somewhere else
inside of the Sendai Colony we find a
damn JoJo character under the name of
Ryu shigori this man currently sits at
77 points and has the highest curse
energy output of all of the players in
the Cullen game so like does he even
surpass Yoda perhaps anyway shooting
over to another Powerhouse called takako
uro as explained that this babe of a
character is the former captain of the
sun moon and star Squad who are a group
of deadly assassins directly affiliated
with a fujiwara clan what you now own
will the fujiwara clan prospered for
around 1200 years from the 600s
dominating the Imperial Court until
1868. so gigabin Giga has probably taken
her directly from a specific time period
throughout those 1200 years and assuming
she's insanely strong it was probably
during the golden period or the hean
period of 794 through 1185 where they
held most of their dominance in the
court anyways skipping over to this bug
who kuroshi which is a special grade
cockroach curse that kinjaku had
released from kiddo's curse Spirit
manipulation and it was probably one of
those like very few special grade
Skittles keeping hidden during the night
parade let's explain that it currently
has 54 points and is lined dormant until
the unfavorable conditions disappear due
to the conflicting abilities in Natures
the four powerhouses Force the standoff
rather than Alliance however they did
lock falls apart when one side
eventually collapses Drew luck to Wyler
you said old school fart is cut down by
Tokyo Jiu Jitsu highs infamous second
year student Yuta akotsu who now has 35
points so like man has literally become
demon mode throughout this part of the
story remember how he had also lost his
uh ranking after the end of jjk zero
well it's explained here that he
reclaimed his rank three months after
the night parade of a hundred demons and
still possesses unusual strength second
only to saturno Gojo so the hype for
this battle is absolutely insane right
now takako and Ryu who are nearby
observe the developing situation and the
simdai colony due to himself to reflect
a while has fallen and is patrolling
shikigami are disappearing Ryu uses his
cocaine to check who defeated dhruv and
discovers the player as due to akotsu
takaku does the same and while she's
glad the ugly shikagami are disappearing
she's concerned about a new threat that
will surely emerge back with Ryu he
realizes that he was only able to get
close to Drew without provoking him
before because he was occupied in battle
with you to these two new Sorcerers both
know that following Drew's defeat
kuroroshi will likely emerge next back
over with our boy though after cutting
down truth he regroups with a crowd of
civilians he's been protecting he tells
them that it's time to head north at the
edge of the barrier but notices a mother
and daughter struggling to go on because
of this he changes his mind and tells
all of the civilians they can rest and
settle the stadium that will serve in
his Drew's base suddenly though he's
interrupted by a buzzing and
collectoring sound that indicates some
sort of danger due to immediately orders
everyone to hurry inside of the stadium
and he draws his Katana he looks out and
sees an overwhelming swarm of cockroach
approaches chasing people it's funny
like cutting myself off for a second you
know it's like a mega miguji Fusion like
The Best of Both Worlds man will murk
anyone when necessary and also save the
helpless as much as possible anyways
anyways ljjk Hannah Montana jumps fourth
thinking he can save the remaining man
but as you to grabs the man's arm he's
unable to pull him away in time and
sadly the Cockroaches Devour the
civilian's lower body then as the
Cockroaches jump from the man's body to
attack you to quickly blocks with his
Katana and notices that all of the bugs
are indeed real and sex reinforced with
curse energy the Swarm attempts to rush
past Utah to Ravish the other civilians
but he summons Rika to stop them the
Demonic Powerhouse himself then uses
that curse devil IQ and smashes down on
a bridge collecting the structure on top
of the Swarm forcing it to go back
towards Utah the special grade sorcerer
then abused his Katana with curse energy
and swings it with enough Force to
create a large blast of cursed energy
that disintegrates the whole swarm in
one shot watching the action from afar
Ryu comments that while you just cursed
energy output isn't anything special his
overall Coast Energy manipulation is
extremely impressive also observing
tsukaku outro states that Utah's overall
curse energy is bottomless and that the
Cockroach curses are disgusting so this
elbargo it's explained that he was a
poor matchup for drove so to play things
safe it went into like a dormant space
until droof was eliminated the curse has
an endless appetite and 18 stimulates
its ability to perform parthenogenesis
which and our monkey bring terms and
that took me five times to say just
means This creepy old bug can
self-reproduce not needing a male or
female partner now awakened the
Cockroach curse is starving and its
instincts immediately lead it to devour
YouTube while preparing the face off
against kuroroshi yudapondus his
objective in this Colony he knows his
resources are finite and it's only a
matter of time before overall allowing
passage in and out of colonies is added
however dangerous players like truth
can't be allowed to leave the barrier
either with the likelihood that there
are other players just like him usually
knows that communication between
colonies is necessary to prevent anyone
dangerous from leaving their game in
addition to the roles Megami proposed in
the meeting with tingen Utah understands
his allies need a means of communication
and a way to move in and out of the
colonies so in total that's four rules
the group needs to create to get a
handle on the culling game which is
actually insane because that's at least
400 points or a majority of the
reincarnations kinjaku has actually
brought back anyways Yuda feels that the
Shibuya incident exhausted all of his
allies and he doesn't want to make his
sense a Killer's best friend again
poised and ready to engage the enemy
player with his Katana usually resolves
to kill kinjaku and obtain 400 points
all on his own so let the absolute
bloodbath begin noticing yuda's battle
starts kuroshi bulks up and reveals a
curse talk called the festering life
sword an enchanted blade that mixes life
and death itself armed with the
festering life sword kuroroshi
ferociously attacks only to have his arm
immediately cut off by Utah the sorcerer
then uses his Katana to pin the kusa's
arm to a rock literally just to harming
it by turning the arm into a freaking
barbecue sword skewer you didn't pulls
up with a dead level backhand strike
that since kuroroshi's getting back
across the water the Cockroach curse
tries to fly up above the bridge but
Yuda who's just too damn quick jumps on
top of the bridge first then grabs and
flings a piece of railing that hits
kuroroshi in the chest taking this
moment Yoda capitalizes on the opening
he created by sending kuroroshi down and
to the water below with a sick diving
slash as the water clears though it's
revealed that the curse managed to stop
juda's blade by using a swarm of
cockroaches Yuda swipes the storm away
with a sword while kuroroshi manipulates
his bugs into a twister of cockroaches
to malevently stand on below uturas are
weird that he's been watched by the two
other players with high scores he knows
he can easily exercise kuroshi by
driving reverse Coast energy into his
body in a similar fashion to how we
revived Yuji in their fight however Yuna
doesn't want the observing players to
see that he can use a reverse curse
technique additionally he can't call
Enrique because she's protecting
everyone else at the stadium kuroroshi
is indeed a dangerous opponent but Yuda
wants to exercise her without relying on
either of his two backup techniques out
of nowhere though this bug somehow
manages to speak which you know actually
makes sense is over time special grades
can like easily develop a language
anyways it asks you to why he's
interfering with his feeding referring
to her not letting her Munch down on
those civilians back there to a tutor
responds by asking the curse white kills
people and kuroroshi simply replies that
it likes the taste of iron then going on
to chart binding over and over again
kuroshi uses its Earthen insect trance
technique to summon small and seek like
curses that carry these unproportionate
looking nut texts with them instantly a
swarm of cockroaches shoot down and
around UDA forcing him to stab the
shallow water below him to create a
shock wave allowing him to hide once
this swarm dissipates the curses from
kuroroshi's previous technique attack
user from behind you just slashes them
apart but sadly the toxins from their
big ass sex blind him for a moment
giving kuroshi an opening the Cockroach
curse retrieves the first three life
sword and slashes at his Target Judo
manages to block with his katana but the
festering life sword shoot something
into his shoulder as a boy darts back he
figured that the curse tool might be
able to shoot projectiles but he
instantly realizes something's wrong and
more insect-like curses suddenly grow
out of his shoulder wound taken by
surprise Yuna tries to cut them off with
his Katana but this gives kuroroshi
another opening to attack closing in the
Cockroach curse slashes Yuta across his
abdomen opening up another wound and
causing more curses to spawn from it Ryu
and takako watching shock as kuroroshi
then grabs you at his body fully
expecting her to devour him yusu though
plays the infamous Uno reversal and
grabs the cursor's face before sinking
his teeth into kuroroshi's exoskeleton
then as he's munching down he drives a
reverse curse energy blast through his
teeth into the Cockroach compromising
the Integrity of its body and exercising
the special grade curse kuroshi Falls to
Paces while you just spit its remains
onto the ground earning himself another
five points from kogane where the curse
Spirit out of the way and Utah in a
vulnerable state uru decides to take
advantage of situation and confronts
them directly levitating upside down
behind a new rival or her Whispers into
juda's ear taking him by surprise before
you can confront the danger directly
though or reduces the dopas curse
technique to heavily distort the space
around them instantly this Distortion
fractures the terrain around her and
launches you to backwards taking the hit
head-on you know minimizes the damage
and starts to wonder how exactly she
caused so much destruction but before he
has time to think Oro follows up her
attack with a punch Yuda is just able to
weave past the hit and tries to counter
with a punch of his own however Oro
grips down and warps the sky around his
fist completely stopping his
counter-attack and turning his hand into
some spaghetti ass noodle which like
reminds me of Harry's hand over the
Quidditch game and Chamber of Secrets
anyways anyways while you just stands
the confused by his distorted appendage
Ro knocks him back with another attack
now out of combat yuda's arm quickly
returns to normal without any damage
leading Juda to assume Ora's curse
technique manipulates space without
actually crushing anything within it
similar to how like a lens crest
abortion that's just an idea but I I
wonder if she could also create some
sort of pocket Dimension or Wormhole
hear me out it does sound kind of crazy
but as you could grab two specific
points in space and distort those points
to make them touch technically that's
how we think a wormhole might work over
a 3D plane and from that it opens up
this series too late the idea of time
travel or a high domain like the fourth
dimension or something anyways you know
it sounds a bit bizarre the reason I say
this is because uru discloses her
ability right now and reveals her curse
technique treats the sky as a surface
for example era can physically grab an
open space making it a tangible object
which in turn allows you to manipulate
it as if it was some sort of curtain
both of the previous attacks on Utah
bypasses defenses and scent of flying so
he figures that there must be some sort
of tractor ability if warped surfaces
are able to accomplish that impatiently
uru waits for opponent to attack so she
can counter with her technique but
instead Judah asks her a question he
asks if a roe wouldn't complain if she
were to be killed and why exactly she's
seeking out conflict he understands that
powerless people get desperate but this
doesn't apply to uro because her curse
technique makes it such a formidable
opponent compared to the majority of
other sorcerers in the culling game uro
explains to him that she doesn't take
receiving a new body lightly as
essentially incarnated Sorcerers have
returned from the shadow realm she feels
like someone without regret wouldn't
have joined the killing game in the
first place so as the first step in her
new life she has prioritizing points and
that's why she's attacking still
confused probably even like more than us
reading right now because it made no
sense to me what she said there Judah
asks if uro has a lover or a companion
she's fighting for the reason he asks
this is because he simply can't
understand why someone would spend time
killing people thousands of years later
even if they have regrets listening to
you to play but on though uru gets more
and more pissed off all culminating at
the point where Yuda asks her how she
could possibly be so desperate that
she'd only return for her own selfish
game I write and literally blowing blood
vessels on a dome Oru asks a future as a
descendant of the fujiwara clan claiming
that someone of his blood wouldn't ever
understand her which I don't think he is
he's a michizani's descendant so I don't
think that's fujiwara someone let me
know down in the comment section below
Ryu though remember that like random
apparently op JoJo's character from
before well his ass interrupts the
conversation by using his insane Granite
blast to far a massive wave of cursed
energy from his head at both players
leaving the previously beautiful city
now just a pile of rubble having
attacked from a nearby rooftop Ryu
claims Yuta and Urus fluorescene is
making him hungry for battle era decides
that there's no reason to let Ryu go now
now that the colonies did look is broken
use it in uru simultaneously decide it's
time to take Ryu out they both Dash in
straight towards Ryu exciting the
long-range fighter who responds with a
volley of cursed energy beams their
weave after the approaching Fighters
Yuna is narrowly able to avoid the
initial barrage using his agility but a
second wave of attacks appears to take
him off guard decimating him and the
bridge he's standing on however once the
Smoke Clears for you who thought he
landed a direct hit notices that Yuda is
gone suddenly Judah leaps up from behind
onto the roof to confront Rio directly
forcing him to realize that you'd use
the whole Rica made in the bridge to
avoid the beams and get out of sights
having successfully closed the distance
between them Yuna attacks the ancient
sorcerer directly before darting back
into his fighting pose and declaring
that it's time to bring the fight into a
close range amused by yuda's display of
skill Ryu asks if fighting up close will
satisfy his hunger elaborating on his
comment Ryu asks if someone should tell
a child in front of her face to calm
down and eat slowly Yuda suggests that
someone should do that and Ryu actually
agrees admitting that it was probably a
bad example lighting up a city Ryu says
he didn't have any major regrets in his
first life where he fought worthy
opponents and had met a good woman even
so he still suffers from a thirst that
no one understands and because of that
he's still unsatisfied he says that
cigarettes have a sweet aftertaste but
his life has never had that kind of
dessert instantly Ryu unleashes a
flowery of attacks causing you to
quickly respond with punches of his own
giving them both a chance to feel for
each other's combat prowess Judah notes
that Ryu has an explosive cursed energy
output combined with very precise and
quick movements even without his
Advanced toughness a direct hit from Ryu
would cause significant damage after
exchanging several blows and parrying
one another both Fighters turn to land a
spinning attack however Ryu clashes his
back against Utah and expels a blast of
cursed energy that sends the letter
flying back off the roof due to crashes
to the top of another building losing
his footing for a moment but quickly
manages to regain his balance
immediately where you heavy notices
stumble follows up with another Granite
blast attack sitting in a beam of energy
directly at user but somehow you're just
able to deflect it with his bare
freaking hands like some Harry Potter
spell without a one level of holy
then Yoda in a damn flash quickly closes
the distance and tries to crush his
opponent with a fierce right hook to the
Dome crushing Ryu into the roof and
cracking the concrete floor below him
however it actually seems that Ryu had
condom into a false sense of security as
he counters with another beam of curse
energy that Utah is unable to fully
overpower as he blasts you to back where
you tells him that you are my desert
Euro who's like just rolled up on the
scene takes advantage of yuda's
unfavorable positioning in mid-air and
targets him with a curse technique let's
explain that technically she doesn't hit
the person with her technique but
strikes the surface of the sky and
steered having revealed the extent of
your Technique or it breaks the surface
like thin ice and smacks your opponent
straight down onto the brick road below
irritated by the interference where you
shoot a wave of curse energy at uro and
tells her that she's in his way telling
him to silence himself though Oru uses
her technique to warp the space around
the cursed energy beam firing it right
back at him and hitting him directly
injured yuruthin manages to return to
the battlefield which amuses uro who
claims it's great that he's tough as
she's going to toy with him eljojo
wannabe who's still recovering from his
own attack notices that Yoda is
constantly using his reverse curse
technique to heal himself and using up
all of his near bottom curse energy
leaped down by his opponent's receding
strength Ryu comes to the conclusion
that Yuda is not the dessert he had been
searching for to quench his gluttonous
thirst thinking on what to do himself
Judah knows that Ryu doesn't Target
civilians but he wouldn't care if they
ended up as collateral damage in an
attack Judo knows that he wanted to put
more distance between fighting and the
stadium where the civilians are just in
case but that isn't likely to happen
anymore instead Judah decides to use his
full strength now he pulls out and puts
on his ring then kills upon Riker and
asks her to give him everything Rick is
suddenly manifest as a curse Spirit
right next to him leaving both Ryu and
uro confused by this tune of events
we're always shocked Yeti wasn't already
using his full power and Ryu doesn't
understand how yuda's curse energy is
already filling back up for those of you
like confused think of Rika like a water
tank of cursed energy and when Yoda
decides to open that tap he can just
refill his deflated curse energy on top
of that break your tears open a chest to
display a freaking arsenal of cursed
tools kept inside her body for you to
choose from so rake of the curse is
technically different to Riker orimoto
and once the young child's spirit
peacefully passed away at the end of jjk
zero the cursed Spirit itself stayed
directly connected to yuda's ring and
while the connection is active Reika is
capable of storing curse energy for Yuta
completing her full manifestation to Aid
him in battle and can even Supply cursed
talks for him though he can only
maintain the sustained connection for up
to like five minutes having chosen the
missile arm Rika attaches the casing
around yudu's right arm to improve his
overall striking power ready to
re-engage in the now three-way battle
Yoda Begins by having Rika saw through
the air towards Arrow who now prepares
who Sky manipulation technique and
response however Utah suddenly create
superlific snake eyes and fangs schedule
of the inumahi clan on his mouth and
activates cursed speech commanding all
of his opponents to not move Oru tries
to cover her ears but she's just too
late and is immediately immobilized
which I wonder if that implies that the
inumaki clan had been around from the
time that uru was previously alive as
she reacts like she knew what the
ability was anyways unable to defend
herself Aura was pummeled by a large
barrage of strikes from both Yuta and
reiker since shooting off Jose then
drops down and launches himself off
wreck his arms like he's a goddamn
volleyball towards uro continuing to
pressure her for you tries to intervene
in their fight and launches a beam of
cursed energy claiming that Yoda's
approach is too soft Ricky though cuts
it off and slices the attack in half
with one hand and pressing Ryu who
believes that Riku might be even more
durable than uter himself irritated by
the pain Rika angrily lashes out
punching Ryu in the face and sending him
flying off their roof he tries to follow
up with another strike but Ryu quickly
counters with an explosive punch of his
own smashing Rika back into the roof of
an opposing building excited with the
potential to satisfy his hunger Ryu
fixes his hair and claims he has an
appetite that calls for an extra large
helping back with the other two though
you just summons a bunch of small flying
shikigami by using strains of his hair
as an intermediary uru destroys one of
them using new technique and claims that
members of the fujiwara are only
standing away because they fear her true
potential going on that typical anime
level Spiel she explains that she is the
leader of his sun moon and star squads
Affiliated directly with the tour of the
fujiwara clan there were assassins that
pursued lives or selfless devotion and
the shadows and didn't even be names a
particular Sorcerer of the fujiwara clan
though gave takako her name only to
execute her as a proxy to cover up his
own crimes of killing someone else and
the clan suddenly though Ura was cut off
from its sentence and cut across her
chest and herps by the shikigami those
trajectories are the shikigami
constitute o domain which uru
immediately recognizes as Drew's
technique remember like that old man
from the very beginning of the fight she
realizes that Judah isn't a cursed
speech user with the ability to summon
shikigami instead he's a sorcerer with
the ability to copy others curse
techniques Yuda proceeds to follow up
and knocks uru down to where Ryu and
Rika are fighting he tries to capitalize
with a straight punch but uro manages to
stop his attack and break his armored
shell with the Icebreaker effect of your
Technique uninjured by this exchange
though you details uro that regardless
of what his ancestors may have done
living for herself will only get her so
far yet those words just hit a complete
block and only served to further annoy
uro who claimed that saying things like
live for others is something only those
who have achieved something can do the
conversation is interrupted though when
they both notice a massive search and
reuse curse energy Ryu thinks his
opponents need to shut up because words
are utterly pointless at this stage of
the fights are you guys already as the
three of them suddenly look at each
other prepare to bring their three-way
battle to a climax the trio of sindo's
strongest sorceress all activate their
domain expansion simultaneously
instantly and like because of the three
overlapping domains they cancel each
other's short hit functions out without
that Advantage for you and uro know that
they need to stop yosa from taking the
initiative by keeping Reika out of the
barrier Ryu knows that he had already
knocked Rika over 20 meters away so it
was unlikely you'd be able to reach the
barrier in time but outside it's shown
that the last vestiges of Rika or
imoto's will inside of Rika couldn't
accept that she was unable to protect
Yuta causing her strength to wretch it
up another notch suddenly kuroroshi yes
remember that damn cockroach from back
at the beginning of the video that just
got milk by user randomly appears and
infiltrates the freaking barrier while
it's cockroaches outside occupy recur so
remember how I said this dude was able
to self-reproduce and all that kind of
stuff well before going dormant kuroshi
actually reproduced via his
parthenogenesis after Judah exercised
the parent roach the country's curse
energy of fear was transferred into the
new Offspring kuroshi the player is
indeed perished but kuroroshi the curse
spirit is still completely active three
overlapping domains are more complex
than two and the conditions imbued
within their barriers complicate things
even further with the addition of an
unexpected Intruder the barriers are
completely compromised and begin to
shatter falling to paces falling out
themselves Yuna notices that uro is
totally focused on kuroroshi obviously
this is due to her technique being at a
complete disadvantage with the roach
because of this Yuna takes the
opportunity and literally kicks uro in
the back while she's distracted sending
her flying towards the ground almost
like cementing her death seeing her
coming down the cursed roach rushes
towards her with the festering life
sword uru tries to respond by activating
her curse technique however as we all
know from the past events with mojito
curse techniques are difficult to use
immediately after using a domain
expansion and uru's ability to
manipulate space Burns away in her hands
leaving it open takura Roshi's assault
the roach curse slashes uro's left arm
and quickly these disgusting and
sick-like curses spawn funny wound
severing her limb completely Rika who's
also there acts quickly by devouring
uro's arm before the roach code and
pressing Ryu he notes that Yuda is
thorough and that it's unlikely that uro
can regenerate her entire arm even if
she uses a reverse curse technique I
write over the loss of her arm root
angrily calls out to The fujiwara
Descendant cutting her off though Ryu
tells her to stop because she and
kuroshi uninvited to his table yes if
you have noticed everything to do with
Ryu ishiguri has something to do with
eating food like the dessert thing from
earlier or now the whole like you ain't
invited to this table you can't eat from
this table type thing anyway anyway
let's explain that ryu's curse technique
is called cursed energy discharge and
he's the only sorcerer capable of
outputting the same amount of power
regardless of if his technique is active
or not instantly he blasts uro and
Karoshi with another jacked up Granite
blast incapacitating Euro and partially
destroying kuroroshi making it simple
for you to exercise with his reverse
curse energy excited for his dessert now
Ryu fixes his drip and welcomes Yuta to
the table he charges his cursed energy
and takes aim while opposite him you
don't know that his own curse technique
has yet to replenish but with Yusuf and
Riker working together to counter the
ancient sorcerer as the next move the
table is set for the final battle as
line that you can only unleash a direct
beam of cursed energy while Rika is
completely manifested even at full power
Judas blasts are slightly weaker than
reuse in order to win The Exchange Yoda
intends on a rapidly building up cursed
energy and firing first before Ryu
reaches maximum power however ryu's Eyes
Express over 400 years of hunger waiting
to be satiated and his gaze pleads with
Yuta to use his full power although Utah
would never find true meaning and
conflict reuse gaze melted his heart
melted my damn heart as well look at
those eyes it's so damn beautiful
anyways Yuda agrees to go all out on
this just once and both Sorcerers
Unleashed their curse energy the blasts
Collide and they curse energy beam
struggle that's extremely reminiscent of
an old-school DBZ Blast Off sadly though
Yuda is quickly overpowered by ryu's
blast the duo are seemingly hit and sent
back into a nearby building which Ryu
immediately expresses How Sweet the
first taste of his dessert was the
gleeful sorcerer is quickly surprised
though when when he begins to feel his
opponent's cursed energy swelling up
wanting a male he desires he screams in
us for another being struggle and
retaliation rikifies a blast of cursed
energy while Utah simultaneously rushes
forward it's showing that Yoda actually
jumped forward at the exact same time
the blast hurt launching him at high
speed towards the enemy sorcerer breaker
is also able to shoot completely on her
own but Ryu believes he's jacked enough
and somehow he blocks The Beam with his
spear hands as well claiming that he can
do whatever you to can he takes aim at
quta and expects to finish him off with
his next attack due to the cursed energy
he extended on top of just using a
domain expansion however as his Granite
blast shoots out an unbeknownst to Ryu
yudhas technique had already replenished
he takes this moment and uses oru's
ability to warp space redirecting ryu's
blast up into the ear shocked where you
realizes tayuda can actually copy
people's curse techniques and tries to
symbolize what condition he must fulfill
to do so he recalls Riker devouring
uru's arm and figures that there must
have been when he satiated the condition
yuru notices ryu's lack of focus
capitalizing on it and scores a direct
hit to ryu's chest with oro's thin
Icebreaker move quickly he follows up
with another combination downward punch
using Riker that hits so hard it causes
Ryu to become bleeding profusely from
his head so I remember how there was
like a time limit on rika's
manifestation well five minutes have now
passed since you to donned his ring
causing the connection between him and
Rick is actually in Ryu takes advantage
of this by hitting Riker with his full
power an attack that was too much for
her to handle even more fully manifested
because of this Reiki quickly reaches
the limit and disappears from the battle
leaving Utah to continue fighting on his
own the big man himself Ryu is excited
that there's even more to their battle
even after clashing at full power he
happily declares that this final course
is the dessert he has been longing for
standing there you do surprises the
Ancient One by grabbing him with both
hands and pushing their weight down so
hard that it cracks the ground Beneath
Your Feet after effectively immobilizing
them both Judah claimed that the fight
is over confusing Ryu while shigori is
looking down at the cracked ground his
Granite Blast from earlier yes remember
that one Juda shot up into the sky using
uro's technique well it rains down to
rexley on Ryu and surprises the
unsuspecting sorcerer completely
toasting him still standing there though
like like an actual champion but still
defeated where you quickly realizes that
he was just hit by his own beam as Judah
redirected it back down using uro's
technique at the same time Ricard hurt
him despite his defeat for he was
satisfied with the high level of battle
he participated in and thanks you sir
now that his stomach is finally full not
gonna lie getting those the terminology
of this saying so damn well and we all
just ate as well as Ryu ishigori did
right here boys anyways anyways
following the end of the battle in the
Sendai Colony you're the first talks to
the defeated uro in order to retrieve
her points she tells you to this like
extremely ominous statement they
probably will 100 play a role later on
in the story she says that his strength
has a limit and she's seen a power
beyond the Horizon of the strongest
Fighters and curses with their very own
eyes in that moment she imagines
sakuna's original form and claims that
such power takes the form of
overwhelming a Christian that disregards
anything else like a Calamity Yuna then
moves on to Ryu who tells him that he's
too soft and he won't receive praise for
his actions he'd replies to him though
that takako also told him something
similar that there was no value in
sparing an opponent's life having heard
this for you were surprised to learn
that uru survived and believes his blast
must have been weakened after using
domain expansion which like I brought up
earlier makes sense as most of the time
after using a domain someone's technique
will slightly falter in comparison to
before the domain was used anyways
anyways Ryu sits up and asks what uru
kept getting upset about during the
fight and asks if it was a lover's
quarrel you'd try splitting him off but
after persisting explains that anything
he could have said to her would have
just led to violence because he's
blessed Ryu doesn't really understand
what you don't mean by this but still
respects his words after a brief break
our man decides to get back on his
mission and asks Ryu to hand over all of
his points the ancient sorcerer is like
kind of initially confused by uh what he
means about this but cocaine explains
that a new rule was added a while back
that allows players to transfer points
to one another Ryu believes he
understands that's why you susped their
lives now but still asks if he would
have killed them without their rule Yuda
suggests that it definitely was a
possibility and smiles while telling Ryu
to just be grateful to his new comrade
which you know could be uh interesting
with that little comment there for what
could happen in the future little use of
Ryu tag team like Duo anyway thanks to
the point transfers from uro and Ryu on
top of the points he already gained from
a lemon 18 dwarf and kuroroshi Yuda now
has a total of 200 points putting him at
the halfway points and their plan to
bring down the culling game so that
officially brings us to the end of this
like Arc here or the smaller Arc and the
next jjk Arc we're going back over to
the Tokyo Colony or the second Tokyo
colony to get some of the craziest
freaking hands you have ever saying with
Kashima versus zakari like it's actually
so freaking brutal but so damn good if
you want to get earlier access to these
videos and possibly other contents like
in the future that I won't release on
YouTube you can check out my patreon
which I will leave down in the
description below and if you guys like
this video and want to watch more
content just like it then make sure you
hit the Subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with pushing my content
to a bunch of new amazing people but
anyway enough of that Vanessa being a
professional did you know it dear Volo
and I will see you all enable bye